let's get a little on my own voice or is
is praising a beach of [ __ ]
McGregor's ass dude I know that are they
fighting yet I don't think so man I hope
they do hope it happens for your boy
so he gets paid oh speaking up beat
Frank's what's up Carl
Keira this is not Keira boys oh wait she
sent him before no she hasn't
I know who you're thinking of she
different girls different guesses mmm
those legs real real thick yeah doing
them deadlifts I dunno you do not like
this yeah I believe she runs a forty
over you they look like two separate
girls though don't they
the one on the Rights a little tan the
one less white as [ __ ] well it could be
the lighting Brennan it could be they're
all sorts of it maybe she went to Hawaii
like you did on the right on the left
True Blood but also yeah I agree they do
look like David could be two different
people and also she has some type of
compression things on her legs you see
that oh yeah like she's uh playing
goalie or some [ __ ] huh oh maybe she's
doing a heavy deadlift you know what
scrape your chin really cat your thighs
aren't small no no they're not I'd like
to see you another Wyatt lift Islands
over there tell us what's going on Kat
can you give us a load on these thighs
over here oh that girl is that looks
like the legs of a power lifter hmm and
she looks like she can squish a
watermelon between without fail do you
guys find that attractive at all what
that give me all that I think oh you
like the thing at all dick strong girl
you know you don't go to the JD is that
not you say spoke yeah
yeah he was go Derek do you go to the
gym and I'll go yeah the other we talked
about it and I wit oh why you go to the
gym cuz I'm with you all the time I've
never heard you talking about working
out ever it's Riley killer man yeah yes
I like emphysema do brag about it would
you be like hey bro shut the [ __ ] up
about clearly what are you doing in
there
no I'd be pretty cool about it being the
CrossFit Games [ __ ] I look like [ __ ]
look at you right now
you look like an assistant manager at an
ant farm dude like meg Ryan in the
morning you'll long your hair's a crumb
I love vamp farms she always have one
day like how many people are in here
[Laughter]
this girl's problem again she has blood
transfusions she's a partner on oh oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah Canadians good
people man good women up there hard
workers oh this girl lift y'all right
off the damn planet yeah
this girl could probably steal a damn
car and take it home you know it's just
steal a car the old-fashioned on her
back brother
freaking true maple syrup right out the
tree it looks like you feel me Oh suck
it right out no roots ry her thighs like
this what do you mean yes got him man
she's just she works hard I don't look
like that though well you everybody to
my man
your ovaries at the top of them so that
I bet she has a donk er in the bass she
got them thigh-ceps boy I like I said
she's got them wing grip
yeah there's a buck right there you look
the other pic now you can't really see
it though there that ain't that there's
nothing for me from being very modest
get on the right she's not modest got a
goddamn get your [ __ ] flies out my
face go hide your dies what is she
supposed to do do ya you take you to the
side like that you know I'm saying like
an FDR self or something or put herself
in a dam put a blanket over her legs and
wheel around right behind man worst
ideas man what else we got beautiful
lady what's her name hell she's patty
here our maple hitter there yeah
[Music]